[Music]
well good morning everybody
thank you for coming to to this session
today I'm flicking it around the room
and thinking there should probably be a
Google next endurance Award for folks
that are here so we're day three if you
are the partners summit this is day four
for you so again credit for being here
if you were to chainsmokers last night
you get extra credit anyway so I think I
hope you share with me the thought that
this has been a great great conference
and I'm gonna share a little bit with
you today about what we're doing and
maven wave-around marketing analytics
and that's about driving the right
message to the right customer for the
right product at the right time if you
are not familiar with maven wave we're a
technology consulting company we deliver
rapid solutions to complex problems for
large companies we work almost
exclusively on the Google cloud platform
we've been a partner of Google's since
2010 we're a premier partner for data
analytics and machine learning and we
were very honored to receive the North
America's services partner of the Year
award for 2017 earlier this week so
that's who we are what I'm hoping will
you'll learn from my session in the next
45 minutes or so is first of all why is
market analytics important why is this
something that you should be focused on
second I'll share a framework with you
that we're using and working with our
clients to deliver marketing analytics
solutions and third we'll map that
framework to a number of hexagons
that represent you know what we're doing
how we're engaging the Google cloud
platform to you know to to deliver for
our customers before we get into get
into a lot of slide where I thought I'd
tell you a quick story and that quick
story is about this company that we have
developed called salient Auto salient
Auto is a an automotive manufacturer
based in our home office in Chicago
annoy if you'd like one stop by our
booth in Moscone South it's about this
long but we have plenty to give away so
stop by later on and and grab mom for
honest but the point of this is that
that I wanted to actually start this
conversation with the demonstration
rather than traditionally leaving the
demo to the end and show you what we've
been doing around marketing analytics
our salient Auto and this is essentially
what I'll talk about in the framework in
a few minutes but the way that we start
this is by aggregating together a lot of
information about the customer and the
customers journey into bigquery we're
using this as a bigquery essentially
using the aggregation point for data
about marketing and data about the
customer and we're using that to drive
dashboards so with helping looking at
this from the perspective of a marketing
manager at an automotive dealership
we're creating a dashboard for him that
lets him see exactly how his marketing
is performing within his dealership and
as you can see we've got a number of
tiles that represent different parts of
his marketing mix a couple of things
that I'll point out to you because this
is not just a traditional
backward-looking dashboard we're also
incorporating recommendations in here a
couple of things that were highlighting
in red first of all he has a budget for
incentives that are driven from sale and
corporate so he there's a regional
incentive plan and this dealership has
$50,000 in the current quarter they
distribute across different vehicles as
additional incentives to their customers
to buy specific products and we're also
going to see in a minute that there are
recommendations that we're making around
with the machine learning algorithm is
making around recommending specific
keywords that they should be purchasing
for for the coming week most likely
since we've made some recommendations
about adjusting keywords actually
changing some budget I don't even read
this in the back but the the the
recommendation says we should optimize
the budget by moving some money from TV
to keywords and also the recommending
that we should update some incentives so
deploying incentives against
civic vehicles and the vehicles that
we'll see in a minute as it's
highlighted in red over here there are
three vehicles on this dealers lot there
are over 60 days old and if you spend
any time working in automotive you know
that after 60 days that's when the
manufacturer stops paying for the
inventory and you as a deal I have to
start paying for it so it's kind of
critical for the dealer to move that
inventory as soon as possible so our
marketing manager maybe will drill down
into a budget planner and look at this
in a little bit more detail you can see
some of the same recommendations on this
top panel here but as we drill in here's
his dealership performance against his
peers the the circle being kind of
average across the peer dealers in his
region and you can see he's over
performing at the moment on TV and under
performing on keywords and that's part
of the recommendation that that we're
going to we're going to be using down on
the bottom here you can see the smart
incentives that that smart incentives
fund that's been available to them we
actually think we're doing a pretty good
job because we have a 75% win rate while
we're deploying smart incentives that's
a good thing so because he's this our
fictitious marketing managers not a very
trusting person we could have cost
automate this next step but I'll show
you the detail behind it so what are the
keywords that were recommending so
there's a model in the salient line
called a Haraka and the recommendation
is that we go ahead and purchase this
the keyword Silvius salient still this
is very difficult to say silver salient
Haraka and bid I'm gonna kill someone
into creative that did that by the way I
think they ambushed me every time is
silver sailing in Taraka
and have it set a daily budget of twenty
three dollars and 33 cents so there's
some rationale down here about why
that's the case I'm not going to go into
that great detail today but we'll go
ahead and just set the keywords so if I
click set keywords there it's going to
take me back to my prior screen and I'll
update the budget and that's going to
move the money and my budget too from TV
into keywords and if I flip ahead to my
AdWords page you'll notice there's
nothing down at the bottom of the page
right now but if I hit refresh
if the demo gods are on our side it will
have gone ahead and populated the that
ad for us not yet we'll hit refresh
again somebody sing the jeopardy theme
for me still not showing up okay
well we'll leave it at that so dem old
owners don't have some problems what
we're doing actually is we're calling
the AdWords API in the background we're
injecting the specific ad with the
specific with a specific budget against
it and we're linking it directly to the
page for that individual to the
individual car try this one more time
[Music]
actually we've managed to do this
without but I'll just let it go so we're
targeting then the specific the specific
car and that that allows us to move you
know move buyers specifically to that
page from that from the purchase anyway
so we were 95 because complete 95
percent complete on the demo today it's
a little less than I would usually
expect okay so so that's that's a way of
thinking about some of the steps we'll
talk about later in terms of how we're
going about doing marketing analytics
build a warehouse of data move you know
create a visualization create some
analytics around that data and then
activate on that so moving on from there
then I think the question though that
when I'm talking to clients what they're
really asking is you know why should
marketing analytics be a priority for my
business I'm going to propose that there
are two things that are critically
important to you here one is the
performance of your business and the
second one is that your customers are
radically changing so let's look at the
first one first performance of your
business so far as to did a report in
2016 where they looked across businesses
and performance of the marketing
function and what they found was
companies that have an integrated well
integrated marketing data and tools
environment really are outperforming
their peers and they're outperforming
their peers roughly but roughly by
beating their budgets each year by over
10 percent or their revenue goals by
over 10 percent so that's a fairly
significant marker for leading
organizations they also recognize that
35 percent of the marketers they talked
to saw return on marketing investment or
Romi as being one of the most valuable
met
tricks that they had to secure
additional budgets for for their
marketing their marketing programs
however almost all the folks that for
cars to talk to found that most of these
market that these marketers didn't have
a way of actually measuring return on
marketing investment and so clearly what
comes from that is really a call for
what we were talking about earlier this
idea of an integrated data set or an
integrated data warehouse that really
spans across the entire marketing
function another way of looking at this
McKinsey 2017 asked business leaders
across functions and across industries
how is big data and analytics affecting
your business you perhaps would expect
that the business the the sector's on
the right-hand side of this chart high
tech energy and sectors like that are
impacted fairly substantially by big
data and analytics what was really
notable to me and perhaps why I have
this chart here is that sales and
marketing across industries was noted by
business leaders as being heavily
impacted by big data and analytics and
so again this is another reason why we
see leading companies now turning
attention to marketing data and
marketing analytics because it is
transformational for their businesses
second thing then your customers and the
way the way that I experienced this is
probably the same way that you do I
would ask you to just reflect on the
journey that you had the physical
journey you had planning and getting to
next over the past past few days how
many humans did you interact with in
that process I'll propose to you that
that number is very very small may be
the person who checked you in at the
hotel but most likely almost all of your
interactions were done without human
intervention and we're expecting and
research is showing us that by 2020 85%
or more of relationships between between
us as customers and companies is going
to be done without any human interaction
and that puts a tremendous burden on us
as marketers to really understand our
customers and of course we
have the same you know complementary
issues or opportunities being presented
to us around the move from desktop to
mobile we have customers expectations
and I'm a customer my expectations of
the people I work with a very very high
I expect them to know me
and so that change in the way customers
are behaving is another driver behind
behind this need for integrated
analytics around marketing and this is
really because our journeys have become
much more complex as customers
we're self-directed now back not that
long ago marketers would essentially be
able to tell you how you should
experience their brand that has
completely been flipped on its head now
we are we as consumers and I'm putting
myself as in your place we as a consumer
I'm deciding how I experience your brand
now what order I do what what order I
ask questions what devices I use where I
am physically with I'm using online or
offline contacts with you all of that is
completely changing the way that the
customer experience is occurring again
that drives the need for us to have a
new way of understanding what how that
relationship works what the customer
journey really is and just a compounded
or maybe it's all a part of the same
thing our are we're more demanding we
expect marketers we expect the brands
that we work with to understand us to
have kind of visit to be able to create
this seamless experience based on an
intimate knowledge about who we are and
what we want and that's that means that
you know we have to really get to
information that is that is relevant and
timely and immediate for for each
interaction that we have with with the
customer so our responses have to be
tailored they have to be immediate they
have to meet our needs for a short
attention span they have to be shareable
they have to be memorable they have to
be completely relevant to your point of
view or your your point in the journey
with that customer with that with that
brand at that time so that takes us to
you know how do we do this so the second
thing I wanted to talk about today as I
said at the outset was talk about a
framework on how we relate to or how we
we talk to our customers and how we're
implementing these types of solutions
for them so we have a fairly simple
marketing analytics framework it
consists of three pieces and I'll go
through each of them in turn building a
comprehensive marketing data warehouse
second developing analytics and
visualization and third then driving on
top of that machine learning solutions
first things first let's talk about the
talk about the framework well I'll put
this in the context of excuse me know
the framework but the the data warehouse
let's put this in the context of a
customer here's a customer she's on the
phone with your contact center well for
you to serve her to meet her
expectations
you need to know who she is you need to
know about her journey you need to know
what her expectations are what is she
expecting to get out of this
conversation that she's having with you
I don't know by the way you probably
also in this interaction want to know
what your objectives are as a marketer
what do you expect what what do you want
her to experience and how do how do you
want to influence the journey that she's
on and so to be able to do that we have
to have this kind of comprehensive
knowledge of her of her experience so
far there are a lot of data sources that
we need to bring to bear here and I in
my prior life as a CMO I experienced the
same challenge that I've talked about
with many marketers here this week and
that is that we have most likely in our
offices anywhere between a dozen and two
or three dozen different marketing
technology applications that we use to
do our jobs and they are often
software-as-a-service their tale it
tailored towards specific parts of the
marketing process they have their own
individual data silos some of the very
large organizations like
salesforce some of them are custom maybe
a warranty system or service system for
the automotive industry there are a lot
of third parties involved only oh yes of
course there's also a fair amount of
information that we we can get from from
our partners at Google so Google ads in
the Google marketing platform we can
bring all that data in through the
bigquery data transfer service all that
becomes available to us fairly quickly
but we also are writing and/or using
third parties to integrate a number of
all these other all these other systems
into this one holistic view of the
customer so we have to be able to access
all that data there is some some quality
control we have to do but we are getting
to the point where we can look across
devices to get that one view of the
customer their journey both online and
offline I think it's important to note
here that our goal in building this is
to look towards the ultimate outcome for
that customer so what what happened at
the end did they buy did they not buy
did they you know what is that what is
our lifetime value either present or
expected for that customer so we're
going beyond just now did I acquire that
customer did they click on my ad I'm
going one to go all the way to what is
the value of that customer and what's
the value what how how did that customer
experience the journey and what create
what what do we learn from that so
there's a lot of data that needs to be
brought together we've been doing this
for for triple a that they came to us a
couple of years ago now and and said gee
we have a problem and our problem is
that we have all these customers and we
have all these business lines but we
can't tell whether what this customer is
doing across business lines so can you
help us with this and yes we put
together what we describe as a modern
data platform it's essentially that that
that marketing data warehouse that I
talked about earlier bringing data from
across the enterprise from across their
marketing applications and from all of
their internal functions to create that
one view of the customer they've been
using that for a number of applications
from a marketing point of view
they've been using it to do better
targeting around their marketing so
they're communicating more effectively
and more more consistently with their
customers their customers are hearing
from them messages are much more
relevant they're also giving able to
deliver a much more consistent customer
experience and customer service so if
you call for roadside service now they
know everything about you they don't
they know more than just you you know
your car needs service they know whether
you're insured by them whether you
whether you're a travel customer this
may not be critical to you when you've
got a flat tire but the the point being
that they have this holistic view and
they can use that to to create much more
seamless interactions between themselves
and their customers so second piece the
the analytics and visualization and this
is where things get obviously a little
bit more custom if you're you're an
automotive manufacturer you're looking
for certain things from from the
analytics for your customers journey
obviously that experience is somewhat
different from if you're selling soap
out or for example laundry detergent but
we we do have some tame templates that
we start from in those conversations
it's all and these are all driven around
again what the marketers needs are on
brand magazine did a survey at the
beginning of 2018 and asked what the
customers what brand marketers
priorities were for 2018 and you'll
notice the three of the top four bars on
this chart so vast majority of folks are
concerned about something about the
customer experience this again drives
this this issue that that we have - we
really have to understand what the
understand what the customer is
experiencing and what how would you
improve that experience and so the
analytics that we they were building the
visualizations that we're building are
really around helping them understand
that customer experience how to acquire
customers effectively how to retain them
so minimizing churn if you have a long
term business a long term relationship
and how to enhance that customer
experience a cratenbarrel
over the last I think this was maybe a
year and a half ago
now they came to us with a problem that
was kind of reflective of this analytics
and visualization problem which was many
of their their internal processes were
difficult
they were very manual they again were
not able to bring bring a visualization
together or bring analytics together
that were helpful to their marketing
team and they weren't able to make
decisions in a timely way
so we developed a set of dashboards for
them we've automated a lot of the
reporting and we've reduced all their
routine reporting by maybe 10x and we're
delivering much better much improved
time to insight for them they turned
this into money by by identifying a real
mismatch between the time that they were
sending paper catalogs through the mail
which are very expensive to their
customers and there was a regional
regional distribution or a regional
demand issue that they hadn't seen
before they were able to time these
campaigns differently and and both
reduce their costs and improve response
times by delivering the right catalog to
the right customers in the region the
right region at the right time the last
piece I'll talk about is the is the
machine learning solutions and here you
can go in a number of different
directions as you might expect I have a
different chart with which I use
sometimes which is kind of a
checkerboard of here about a dozen
different sample machine learning
solutions you saw a couple earlier in
the demonstration where we're targeting
you know what are the right keywords to
select and one of the what is the right
bid level what for for a specific
vehicle and how do we select the right
incentives to go on to vehicles that
have been on the lot a long time and a
couple of other other you know kind of
samples for you segmentation customer
segmentation based on this holistic view
becomes much more empowered we're
talking now about being able to be -
it's a segment based on specific
behaviors in close to real-time if not
actual tinium it's not actual real-time
so we're able to really create much more
meaningful segments being able to
address specific offers to segments on a
much more fine-tuned basis because of
our more holistic view the second thing
that we're doing which again has been
difficult for marketers to do in the
past is to really understand attribution
which is now that we're looking at a
complete data set which spans all the
way from your first contact with a brand
all the way through purchase or non
purchase we're able to do use you know
machine learning techniques to
understand the value of each marketing
channel so that that allows us now to
say that in in this particular context
for this segment of customers digital is
more valuable than email or digital is
more valuable than search or vice-versa
impact of that is pretty significant we
take that with our customers all the way
through optimization and into marketing
mix modeling so you can now Sri shape
your budgets based on a complete
understanding of what the actual sales
impact is of the investments that you've
made in each individual customers
journey going back to our friend on the
phone earlier that means that we can can
go to her and we can knowing what we do
know now about her journey we can take
that nest base next best action we can
target the offer to her in this case
through the contact center script that
she's using or those she's being exposed
to to get her on her journey into a
place where she has the big best
customer experience that she can get
from you while at the same time you're
managing her towards the outcomes that
are most profitable for you so we
activate a lot of these machine learning
models through through these different
channels and of course this varies
customer by customer for their client by
client that we're working with but but
activation now is really something in a
machine learning driven activation is
something that is a reality it really is
allowing us at this point to target
individually ripe ripe product right off
for a right customer right time right
channel I would love to stand here and
say that we can do all this overnight
clearly we can't and the way that the
way that we approach this with our
customers is to think of this in an
agile way and we're we develop software
as in other parts of our business for
our clients and we use agile as our core
methodology there and while it may be
well you may not expect that this
translates directly into what we're
doing for for marketers it does because
we're essentially following a an
iterative process in delivering
solutions to them we think about it in
these five phases and and we would we
would tend to go around the circle
multiple times for for a for an
engagement so first of all collecting
and transforming data so collecting as I
said earlier we have a whole host of
different source applications that we're
drawing data from transforming that data
and making it available in the in the
data warehouse analyzing and visualizing
that data so analysis is great but it's
not useful unless you can actually see
it and have folks make decisions on it
so analyze and visualize and then
activate that through the marketing
channels that I said earlier so actually
connecting back generally through api's
to those those delivery systems so
you're delivering delivering the the
right message to the right customer
right time we go through this cycle
multiple times it's important that you
not get stuck at any one point I
encourage you if you're going down this
path to think about use cases first
what's the data that drives the use case
that drives value go round the cycle get
some get some return on the investment
show leadership that you are painted
this is essentially paying for itself
that's going to secure the investment to
do the next iteration and the one after
that and that's the way that I've been
doing this for quite some time and in
our you know we're able to move forward
with these projects pretty rapidly and
at the same time show return to the
business and there's nothing like
there's nothing like showing a monetary
return on this investment to to secure
investment for the next cycle
so that's that's the journey and I would
encourage you to think about it as a
journey so you can map those phases to
the cloud platform products that we're
using as you'd expect bigquery is is the
home and as I've described earlier
bigquery is the home for the data
warehouse that we do warehouses that we
build we use other tools from the GCP
suite to ingest data whether it's
streaming or batch from all these
different applications for analytics we
use data lab we use the cloud ml engine
to to do analytics based on based on
what's in bigquery of course many of
these many of the ML capabilities in
them merging into bigquery so so a lot
of this is going to end up probably in
that one hexagon but but we've been
using a number of these tools in the
past to get us to this point
for visualization data studio is ramping
up faster and faster we're getting a
look now getting a lot of traction now
in using data studio with our clients we
do use partner products and I think my
colleagues on the Google side you know
rec recognize that clients have
investments in in tableau and in looker
and so as a as a services organization
we certainly work with those those
solutions to to deliver to deliver the
visualizations they're looking for and
then in activation this is the this is
where we're publishing we can publish
solutions from the machine learning that
we're doing as api's and they can be
conceived that way some of the marketing
technologies that we work with are still
batch oriented and some of the data is
not so volatile you need to have an API
so you can you can you know deliver
through batch as well but we and that's
that's essentially the way we're
delivering and activating to to each of
these technologies so that gives you a
sense of the scope of of the of how
we're delivering and how the how our
customers are integrating
they're marketing analytics or
delivering a marketing analytics using
the Google cloud platform
so hopefully that that gives you an idea
of how we as maven way were working with
the Google cloud platform to to deliver
against the goals of marketing analytics
you know as a former CMO wish I'd had
this a few years ago I think it is
really game-changing for the clients
that we're working with and I'll just
leave you in summary with with these
these three three thoughts you know
first of all really this integrated
marketing analytics is is a is a marker
now of high-performing marketing
organizations and you know the leading
enterprises that we're working with
recognize this is game-changing for them
if you think back to that McKinsey chart
that I showed earlier analytics and big
data are transformational for sales and
marketing across all industries it's not
a one-size-fits-all solution but it's
transformational for all and so this is
really a marker of the of the the
companies that are that are going to be
leading in their industries a
comprehensive marketing data warehouse
is is essential foundation it doesn't
all get built in one day but it is
really the foundation both for doing
analytics and visualization and then
getting to machine learning so the
machine learning is going to deliver the
insights and actions that are going to
delight their delight your customers at
the end of the day it's all about the
customer experience and delighting that
customer last and most importantly is
this is a journey this is not something
that's going to happen overnight but if
you start now you will be ahead of your
competitors Iraq and look at that five
five circle chart and you know start
with collecting that essential data for
that first use case deliver some value
and you'll you'll be ahead of the curve
I think on on your analytics your
marketing environment versus those of
your competitors so that's all I had to
say on this this morning I would be
happy to answer questions I hope you
found this valuable I know there's only
a couple of hours left but if you'd like
to talk further I'll be in our booth in
Moscone south
for the rest of the afternoon so have a
great rest of the day and thank you for
being here I appreciate it
[Music]